[Musique]
et des dizaines des centaines de
citrouilles avant de creuser première
étape il faut bien choisir sa jack
o'lantern la meilleure espèce quoi qui
la trouvaient sept citoyens parce
qu'elle est lourde
direction l'atelier il faut maintenant
sculpter un premier dessin en effet au
feutre
histoire de ne pas se tromper le
creusage donc ces faits par les enfants
une fois qu'on a ouvert la citrouille
les enfants up à creuse et enlève tous
les filaments qu'à l'intérieur auquel
soit tout propre nous on a les couteaux
donc comme c'est dangereux en alléguant
et on la découpe en faisant avec eux en
fonction de ce qu'ils veulent je la
grandit un peu celui là une fois la
citrouille terminer certains ont déjà
programmé leur soirée d'halloween
halloween c'est à fait clair et toi tu
va l'utiliser pour halloween
oui on va faire une activité la nuit
d'halloween dans la forêt il y aura des
scènes des animateurs qui vont faire les
activités qui vont lui faire peur et il
y aura des surprises
vous n'avez pas encore votre citrouille
pas d'inquiétude les fermes de gally
propose des ateliers jusqu'au mardi 31
octobre alors rigolotes ou effrayantes
[Rires]